نعم العمليه العسكريه لا تزال متواصله حتى
هذه اللحظه وصلت قبل قليل دفعه جديده من
الاليات العسكريه نحو مخيم طول كرم على
وقع العمليه العسكريه المتواصله في المخيم
هنا نرصد حاله من من الدمار وسط الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه وتجريف
للجرافات الاسرائيليه التي تعمل على تسهيل
حركه الاليات العسكريه في بعض المناطق
بالتزام مع هذه الاعمال قبل لحظات قليله
كان هناك حمله اعتقالات خرجت من بعض
المنازل في في هذا الطريق لعدد من
المعتقلين تم لربما اخذهم الى النقطه
العسكريه ريثما تاتي الاليات العسكريه
المتخصصه لنقل هؤلاء المعتقلين الى مركز
التحقيق في شارع السكه الذي والذي اقامه
الاحتلال منذ بدايه هذه العمليه العسكريه
على العموم داخل المخيم لا يزال الاحتلال
يحاصر المخيم في حاله تدمير واسعه وتخريب
لممتلكات الفلسطينيين عشرات المنازل
اقتحمها الاحتلال دمر ممتلكاتها وعاث خراب
وفساد في تلك الاماكن مخيم نور طولكرم في
هذه اللحظات وبحسب حقوقيون هو اصبح بالفعل
منطقه منقوبه نتيجه للاعتداءات والدمار
والخراب الواسع في المنازل هناك تفجير ل
عدد من المنازل قبل قليل كان بفعل وهي
منازل تعود اما لاسرى محررين او
لمطاردته وجنود الاحتلال بداوا بالفعل هنا
كما تشاهدون هم قوى راجله في المخيم تقتحم
المنازل منزلا تلو الاخر تقوم بعمليات
التمشيط والتفتيش الواسعه في عده
منازل القناصه الاسرائيليه ايضا منتشره في
كافه ارجاء المنطقه الاحتلال دفع بتعزيزات
عسكريه جديده الى المخيم وحركه الاليات
العسكريه لا تزال متواصله في عده احياء من
المخيم حاله الحاله الانسانيه الاطفال
نفذت لديهم ال سبل الحياه الاساسيه من
حليب
من احتياجات اساسيه بعض الطعام في عد من
المنازل اصبحت خاليه من الطعام نتيجه
لاستمرار الحصار ومنع الفلسطينيين من
الخروج من المخيم بالتزامن مع هذه العمليه
العسكريه وهذا الحصار المتواصل منذ ما
يزيد عن 35 ساعه على هذه العمليه العسكريه
ايضا الاحتلال دفع الى مخيم نور شمس في
عمليه عسكريه واقتحام ضمر خلاله بعض البن
التحتيه استشهد واعلن عن
استشهاد شهيد سادس في مخيم نور شمس بعد
الاعتداء عليه هنا وقبل لحظات قليله ايضا
كان هناك حديث عن شهيد جديد او حتى اصابه
عفوا خطيره نتيجه لاليات الاحتلال وجنود
الاحتلال الذين اطلقوا النار ويطلقون
ويستمرون في اطلاق النار صوب الفلسطينيين
بشكل كامل على العموم الاقتحام لازال
متواصل والعمليه العسكريه حتى هذه اللحظه
لا تزال متواصله هنا في مخيم ط الكرم وسط
الاشتباكات المسلحه التي لا تزال متواصله
حتى هذه اللحظه والانفجارات التي تسمع بين
الفينه والاخرى والتي بعضها ناجم عن اعمال
المقاومين والبعض الاخر ناجمه عن تفجير
الاحتلال لبعض المركبات وبعض المنازل
وايضا تدمير لعدد من المنشات التجاريه
داخل مخيم طول كرم